Du kannst.
Guten Tag.
Atish ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Diensthabende Arzt tätig
und würde mit Ihnen diesen Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Okay.
Sind Sie damit eigentlich verstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache jemand hilft mir.
Ja, ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Gut.
Ich werde jetzt ein paar persönliche Fragen stellen.
Dann gleich zu Ihnen aktuell übergehen.
Okay?
Darf ich Ihren Namen erfahren?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich heiße Natalia Kramer.
Natalia Kramer.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben?
Ja, ja.
N, A, T, A, L, I, A.
Das ist Natalia.
Und Kramer K, R, A umlaut.
Also, ä, m, e, r.
Natalia Kramer.
Frau Kramer.
Frau Kramer, genau.
Frau Kramer, wie hatten Sie und wann Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 76 Jahre und ich bin am 4.08.49 geboren.
49?
Mhm.
Okay.
Wissen Sie, äh, wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, also in meinem Ausweis steht, dass ich 1,68 bin.
Vielleicht bin ich inzwischen ein, zwei Zentimeter kleiner.
Man schrumpft ja mit dem Alter.
Und ja, mein Gewicht weiß ich zu genau.
Ich wiege so ziemlich 80 Kilo, ja.
80 Kilo?
Mhm.
Wie groß sind Sie mit der Ola Mitte?
1,68 Meter.
Okay, Frau Kramer.
Was will Sie zu uns heute, wie können Sie Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also, ich hab mit einmal solche heftigen Schmerzen.
Also, das sind ...
Also, das ist so im Rücken und zieht bis in den Bauch rein.
Und in den Rücken hoch.
Und es geht sogar bis in den Oberschenkel rein, ja.
Also, praktisch die ganze linke Seite,
da tut es mir so heftig weh und es krampft so richtig zusammen.
Und das sind ...
Also, so starke Schmerzen, das hat so ein bisschen angefangen
vor zwei Tagen.
Und jetzt sticht es und zieht.
Also, ganz übel, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe, dass Sie zwei Tage Rücken-Schmerzen ...
Ja.
... mit linksseitigem Oberschenkel ausstrahlen.
Und die Schmerzen sind krampfartig.
Sind?
Krampfartige, oder?
Ja, ja, genau, ja.
Und es sticht und zieht.
Ja, und was mir auch aufgefallen ist,
also, irgendwas ist mit dem Wasserlassen.
Also, ich muss ständig auf die Toilette,
und es tut sehr, sehr weh.
Und es brennt.
Und ja, heute Nacht musste ich auch,
ich glaub, viermal bin ich aufgestanden.
Weil ich immer wieder das Gefühl hatte,
ich muss jetzt zur Toilette.
Und heute Nacht hab ich mich auch jetzt so schlapp gefühlt
und so schlecht.
Ich hab mit einem Mal gefroren und ...
Ja, obwohl ich im Bett lag, war mir mit einem Mal eiskalt.
Und ich hab so gezittert.
Und schlecht ist mir vor Schmerzen wirklich.
Okay.
Frau Klemmer,
wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer numerischen Skala?
Von 0 bis 10.
Wobei 0 ist keine Schmerzen.
Und 10 ist unerträglich Schmerzen bedeutet.
Na ja, und?
Ja, wie kann man das beschreiben?
Das ist ein bisschen schwer.
Vielleicht so zwischen 6 und 7 oder so.
Okay.
Ähm ...
Schmerzen auf der oberen Schmerzen
in der anderen Körperregion aus.
Na ja, eigentlich ist das so auf die linke Seite beschränkt.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass es nicht so ist.
Also, auf der linke Seite beschränkt.
Auf den Rücken, auf die Seite.
Da tut es überwiegend weh, ja.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen vermindert oder starker?
Also, ganz starken Schmerzen hab ich natürlich,
wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe.
Aber das sind dann andere Schmerzen.
Das sind dann dieses fiese Brennen beim Wasserlassen.
Das tut richtig weh.
Und ...
Dann hab ich eigentlich auch das Gefühl,
dass es dann auch im Rücken gerade noch mal schlimmer wird.
Und wenn ich dann wieder im Bett liege
und wieder mich schön warm mache,
hab ich das Gefühl,
dass es ein klein bisschen besser auszuhalten ist.
Und ich glaub auch, dass es im Liegen ein klein wenig besser ist,
als wenn ich jetzt rumlaufe, ja.
Okay.
Äh ...
Haben Sie Fieberprogramme?
Also, ich fühl mich tatsächlich heiß, aber ich hab mich nicht gemessen.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, äh ...
Sie haben Schütterfrost.
Ja, also, heute Nacht hab ich das vor allen Dingen.
Da war mir mit einem mal ganz kalt und ich hab so gezittert.
Und dann hab ich mich schön warm zugedeckt.
Und ja, ich war eigentlich zu schlapp.
Am liebsten hätte ich mir noch einen warmen Tee gekocht,
aber ich war irgendwie zu schlapp. Ich konnte es gar nicht.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter ...
Atemnot oder Husten?
Nein, nein, nein. Husten muss ich nicht, nein, nein.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzklopfen, Herzstorpein?
Nein, nein, ich hab nur diese Schmerzen
im Rücken und beim Wasserlassen. Das ist richtig übel, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Wasserlassen Farbeveränderungen ...
Das war es?
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass es hier Wasserlassen
Farbeveränderungen gibt?
Also, ich geh ja nun alle ständig auf die Toilette.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass es ein bisschen dunkler aussieht als normal.
Okay.
Und es stinkt auch ziemlich übel. Also, es riecht nicht gut.
Stinkt. Okay.
Wie häufig müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Also, bestimmt häufiger als jede Stunde.
Also, ja, also, mindestens jede Stunde einmal.
Und in der Nacht ja, vielleicht alle zwei Stunden.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, manchmal bin ich so ein bisschen verstopft.
Dann muss ich so ein Granulat einnehmen gegen Verstopfung.
Das hilft mir dann eigentlich immer ein bisschen.
Aber das nehme ich nicht regelmäßig.
Das nehme ich nur, wenn ich das wirklich brauche.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Na ja, also, im Augenblick ist der nicht gut.
Heute mochte ich nicht viel essen und gestern auch nicht.
Aber normalerweise schmeckt es mir eigentlich gut.
Ja, ich muss halt ein bisschen aufpassen,
weil ich schon ziemlich lange so einen Alterszucker habe.
Aber ja, eigentlich ...
Also, habe ich das ganz gut im Griff mit den Medikamenten.
Und da muss man ja auch nicht so strenge Diät halten.
Also, eigentlich schmeckt es mir schon sehr gut, ja.
Aber jetzt, wie gesagt, die letzten Tage
haben sie nicht viel essen.
Ich vermute, dass sie nicht gut schlafen.
Nein, heute Nacht habe ich ganz schlecht geschlafen, wirklich.
Aber normalerweise geht es eigentlich.
Kann ich eigentlich schon ganz gut schlafen, ja.
Das ist jetzt nur so die letzten Tage,
dass es halt wirklich übel war.
In letzter Zeit haben sie bemerkt,
ihren Gewicht abzugenommen.
Na schön, wäre es, wenn ich ein bisschen abgenommen hätte.
Aber nee, habe ich leider nicht.
Ihren Gewicht ist stabil, oder?
Bitte?
Stabil, oder?
Die harte ist immer gleich, ja.
Okay.
Frau Krämer, ich möchte wissen,
ob Sie rauchen oder Alkohol trinken.
Ja, die Sünden, ja.
Also, ich rauche ...
Also, ja, inzwischen nur noch so eine halbe Schachtel am Tag, ja.
Halbe Schachtel am Tag?
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ach, schon ewig.
Schon als junge Frau habe ich angefangen.
Früher habe ich mehr geraucht.
Da habe ich eine ganze Packung am Tag geraucht.
Und jetzt sind sie auch so teuer geworden und so.
Und jetzt, ein bisschen weniger rauche ich jetzt schon.
Wie gesagt, früher ein Päckchen am Tag.
Und jetzt, vielleicht seit 10 Jahren, 15 Jahren,
dass ich nur noch ein halbes Päckchen am Tag brauche.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke sehr gerne abends mal ein Glas Rotwein.
Oder auch im Sommer, wenn es warm ist,
trinke ich auch gerne eine Flasche Bier.
Oder auch mal, ja, wenn es sehr warm ist, zwei oder so.
Und wenn es was zu feiern gibt, natürlich auch mal ein Glas Wein.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich,
aber das ist eine Routinefrage.
Hatten Sie oder haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Nein, also das habe ich nie probiert.
Alkohol und Zigaretten, ja, aber Drogen?
Nein, da habe ich mich nie dran getraut.
Gut.
Frau Krömer, haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten
gegen die Besonderheit?
Ja, also ich habe so ein bisschen,
so eine Empfindlichkeit bei Hausstaub.
Ja, also da muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich muss also die Betten oft beziehen
und immer gut sauber machen.
Und Hausstaub, ja, da kriege ich halt so ein bisschen Atemprobleme.
Atemprobleme, okay.
Haben Sie noch etwas Allergien?
Nein, sonst kann ich eigentlich alles vertragen, ja.
Okay.
In Ihrer Familie gibt es bestimmte oder wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ja, das weiß ich halt, alle haben.
Also mein Vater hatte auch schon diesen Alterszucker
und ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Und einer meiner Brüder, der hat auch den Alterszucker
genau so wie ich.
Und der andere Bruder, da weiß ich,
der ist aber ja ein bisschen jünger noch,
der hat nur gesagt, dass er eben hohen Blutdruck hat.
Und das hatte eben mein Vater auch.
Ja, das scheint so in der Familie zu sein.
Ist Ihre Mutter gesund?
Nein, die lebt natürlich auch schon lange nicht mehr.
Es tut mir leid, zu hören.
Ja gut, ich bin 76 Jahre alt,
müssen meine Eltern sein.
Also es ist ja nicht erstaunlich, dass die heute nicht mehr leben.
Okay, wissen Sie, warum Ihre Mutter gestorben ist?
Ja, die haben damals gesagt, das wäre irgendwie ein Herzproblem gewesen,
dass die also so was wie einen Infarkt gehabt hat oder so was.
Aber was da wirklich genau war, kann ich gar nicht sagen.
Okay.
Frau Krömer, sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Wegen besonders Kinderkrankheit oder Covid-19?
Kinderkrankheit ist ja schon eine ganze Weile her.
Also als Kind bin ich, ja, bin ich schon richtig geimpft worden.
Und ja, was ich jetzt auch gemacht hab,
natürlich, als diese große Corona-Geschichte war,
da hab ich mich mehrfach impfen lassen.
Das hat man ja den alten Leuten empfohlen.
Und zur Grippeimpfung geh ich eigentlich auch jedes Jahr.
Im letzten Zeit waren Sie im Ausland?
Im Ausland? Nee.
Also ich bin schon ewig nicht mehr weit verreist.
Ich war immer nur zu Hause oder eben hier so Freunde besucht,
Kinder besucht, aber im Ausland war ich nicht.
Reiben Sie regelmäßig Schupport?
Naja, in meinem Alter.
Also was ich tatsächlich noch mache, ich geh einmal in der Woche,
geh ich zum Squaredance.
Das ist so, dass man in so einer Reihe tanzt.
Und das macht viel Spaß.
Und man ist unter Leuten und bewegt sich so ein bisschen nach Musik.
Und man muss ein bisschen sich konzentrieren.
Das tut mir ganz gut, ja.
Ja, sehr gut.
Frau Kramer, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin schon lange verwitwet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir hatten drei Kinder,
aber die sind natürlich jetzt schon alle erwachsen.
Und die leben auch nicht alle hier in der Stadt.
Ein Kind lebt hier in der Stadt, die anderen sind auswärts.
Aber ich seh die hin und wieder.
Aber ich lebe alleine, ne?
Frau Kramer, vermute ich, dass Sie rennt.
Aber früher ...
Ja, ich bin schon lange im Ruhestand, ja.
Was hat Sie gemacht früher?
Was ich vorher gemacht hab? Ich war im Finanzamt tätig.
Finanzamt.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Alterszuckerkrankheit.
Ja, also diesen Alterszucker, ne?
Seit wann haben Sie diese Krankheit?
Das hat man, glaub ich, so vor 15 Jahren.
15, 20 Jahre, schon lange eigentlich.
Ähm ...
Ja, also ...
Ich denke mal, ja, also wenigstens 15 Jahre schon.
Außer Zuckerkrankheit leiden Sie an anderen?
Ja, ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck hab ich natürlich auch, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Ach, auch schon so ...
Seit ich so Mitte 50 bin,
das fing alles so an mit den Wechseljahren.
Da wurde alles schlechter.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Als Kind hab ich natürlich die Mandeln rausbekommen und ...
Ähm ...
Was ist denn noch mal?
Am Ellenbogen hatte ich so einen Schleimbeutel.
Aber das war nur so eine kleine ambulante Operation.
Da konnte ich danach wieder nach Hause.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Also regelmäßig nehme ich das Metformin halt morgens und abends.
Und dann hab ich noch für den ...
Oder gegen den hohen Blutdruck hab ich noch Ramipril.
Da nehme ich morgens aber nur eine Tablette.
Also so ganz wild ist das nicht mit dem Blutdruck.
Wissen Sie, Dosierung, Metformin und Ramipril?
Bei Metformin, das ist 1000.
1000 Milligramm und Ramipril?
Ramipril 5 ist das, glaube ich.
Morgens.
Okay.
Frau Krämer, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich möchte kurz eine Zusammenfassung machen.
Sie haben seit ungefähr zwei Tagen ...
... besonders linksseitige Rückenschmerzen
und ein bisschen Bauchbereich.
Und sehr häufig Wasserlassen.
Ich muss sehr häufig Wasserlassen, ja.
Oh, das schmerzt, ja.
Der Urin, ja, der ist dunkel, genau.
Ja, richtig übel.
Genau, das ist richtig.
Ja, ist denen übel oder schwindelig?
Übel ist mir ...
Aber schwindelig eigentlich nicht, nee.
Aber ich muss mich jetzt nicht übergeben.
Eigentlich ist das nur so eine allgemeine Schwäche
und ein Krankheitsgefühl, so, ne?
Haben Sie Taupassgefühl oder Krippeln im Bein?
Nein.
Nein, nein, nee, so was habe ich nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie bemerkt,
Ihre Hautfarbe verändert im betroffenen Bereich besonders?
Also, habe ich jetzt nicht hingeguckt.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die Haut eine andere Farbe hat.
Nein, nein.
Okay. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich will jetzt natürlich nur wissen, wo das herkommt
und was man dagegen tun kann, vor allen Dingen natürlich, ja.
Ja, Frau Krömer, ich vermute, dass Sie eine
Harn-Rick-Infektion haben.
Aber es ist sehr früh, etwas genau zu sagen.
Dann werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann kann man Blut- und Urinprobe abnehmen.
Und ein paar andere Untersuchungen, zum Beispiel Bauchultraschall.
Ultraschall, das ist ja nicht schmerzhaft, ne?
Ja, Ultraschall ist keine schmerzhaftige Untersuchung.
Und hat keine Strahlen.
Das ist gut, ja.
Und da kann man auch schon was sehen, meinen Sie?
Ja, danach, wenn alle Informationen vorliegen,
werde ich Ihnen schrift für schrift informieren.
Okay.
Bitte legen Sie auf die Liege, ich komme gleich.
Ja, okay, dann lege ich mich da schon mal hin.
Gut, ja, danke.
Okay, Sie sind hervorragend in der Zeit.
Ja, gerade ist die Uhr abgelaufen.
Ich möchte jemanden noch was fragen.
Nee, ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Früher schon mal, nee, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, danke.
Frau Krömer, haben Sie erbrochen?
Nee, habe ich aber auch gerade gesagt, ne?
Er hat ja nachgefragt nach Übelkeit und Schwindel.
Und da habe ich gesagt, ja, Übelkeit habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt.
Aber ich musste mich nicht übergeben, ich musste nicht erbrechen.
Danke.
Ich habe das akustisch nicht gehört.
Haben Sie Veränderungen beim Zugang bemerkt?
Na ja, also ich habe normalerweise immer ein bisschen Verstopfung.
Und da muss ich auch hin und wieder mal Medikamente nehmen.
Aber in diesem Zusammenhang ist nichts anders beim Stuhlgang.
Okay.
Aber wenn man ehrlich ist, hat wahrscheinlich jede Frau
irgendwann mal Blasenentzündung gehabt und kennt das.
Aber jetzt so die mit solchen Schmerzen,
das hat sie noch nicht gehabt.
Also, guten Abend, Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen
und möchte Ihnen diesen Falkurs vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich. Können Sie ein bisschen näher ans Mikro?
Ich höre Sie ein bisschen schlecht.
Okay. Danke.
Es geht um Frau Natalia Krömer, die 76 Jahre Patientin.
Geboren am 4.08.1940.
Sie ist 1,78 Meter groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen
seit zwei Tagen,
progredienter linksartige Flankbereiche Schmerzen
außerdem
Vor, stellte sich vor, also?
Vor. Die Schmerzen strallen linksartige Oberschenkel aus.
In den linksartigen Oberschenkel?
In den linksartigen Oberschenkel aus.
Die Schmerzen sind stickend, sehend und krampfartig.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 bis 7 von 10.
Auf einer nummerischen Skala.
Es gibt keine bestimmten Auslöser.
Sie hat Polylacry, Dyspherie, Fatigue
und Schütterfrost.
Sie hat Fibrikerfühl, aber nicht gemessen
in der Körpertemperatur.
Und auch berichtete sie, dass ihr Hirn
ein bisschen dunkel ist und stinkt.
Oh ja.
Sie muss jede Stunde auf die Toilette gehen.
Auch nach jeder zwei Stunden muss sie auf die Toilette gehen.
Aber nur jetzt, sonst normalerweise nicht, ne?
Ja, seit zwei Tagen hat sie diese Beschwerden.
Außer dann, sie hat Nausea, aber
musste sie nicht Emesis.
Sie musste sich nicht übergeben oder beschreibt keine Emesis.
Fragen nach Atemnot, Pusten, Schwindelich,
Hautfarbeveränderungen,
neurologisches Symptome,
würden verneint.
In der Vegetative-Anamnese
gab es an, dass sie seit zwei Tagen
wegen dieser Beschwerden in Appetens und Insomnie.
Ja.
Sie hat gegen Hausstaub allergisch.
Ist allergisch, ne?
Ist allergisch oder hat eine Allergie?
Wegen dieser Allergie
äußert sich sie mit Atemproblemen.
Sie hat keine bestimmten Unfertigkeiten.
Der Impfstatus ist aktuell.
Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Als sportliche Aktivitäten tanzt sie einmal pro Woche.
In einer Gruppe, ja, sehr schön.
In der Familienanamnese
leidet ihr Vater an Diabetes mellitus type 2
und arteriöle Hbartoni.
Ihre Mutter ist wegen einem Myokartinfarkt
wahrscheinlich gestorben.
Sie hat zwei Brüder, von denen einen
hat Diabetes mellitus type 2 und anderen
leidet an arteriöle Hbartoni.
In der Noxanamnese
ist sie Raucherin.
Seit ungefähr zwei Jahren.
Sie ist eine Schleifkrankung.
Seit ungefähr 15 Jahren.
15? 15 Jahren.
Halbe Schachtel pro Tag geraucht.
Davor raucht sie ein Schachtel pro Tag.
Oh ja. Ungefähr 35.
Jahre.
Sie trinkt abends
täglich Rotwein und
mit einem Feier oder
Freunde treffen ein Glas Bier.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie ist verwitwet.
Sie hat drei Kinder.
Sie wohnt allein.
Sie hat drei Erwachsene.
Sie ist derzeit Rentner.
Früher hat sie als Finanzamt tätig.
Beim Finanzamt. Sie war Angestellte
im Finanzamt. Das Finanzamt ist ja eine Behörde.
An Finanzamt angestellte.
An Vorerkrankungen
leidet sie an Diabetes Miletus
Typ 2 ungefähr 20 Jahren.
Und leidet sie an Arterial Hipertonie
ungefähr 25 Jahren.
Würde bei ihr
als Kindheit eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt.
Und eine
Ellenbogen-Bursitis
wegen einer Ellenbogen-Bursitis eine
Ambulanz-Operation durchgeführt.
Ah ja. Aber das war nicht in der Kindheit.
Ja.
Sie nimmt regelmäßig mit 100.000 Milligramm
morgens und abends.
5.000 Gramm morgens ein.
Frau Oberarztin, aufgrund der Ananase
gehe ich von einer
Pneumophritis.
Was könnte es differential diagnostisch noch sein?
Differential diagnostisch kommen
Dyskosprolaps oder Nierensteine.
Ja.
Das kommt in Frage. Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich
die Patientin zunächst körperliche Untersuchung
mit der Parameter gemessen.
Ja. Und worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich, ob
Abwehrspannung, Lostatschmerzen, Druckschmerzen
vorhanden sind oder in den
Flankbereich eine Druckempfindlichkeit.
Ja, genau. Gut.
Und wonach schauen Sie noch?
Dann werde ich die Patientin Blut abnehmen
und Urinprobe prüfen.
Welche Parameter lassen Sie
labortechnisch bestimmen?
Dabei würde ich Blutbildentzündungparameter
CAPBSG, Nierenwerte,
Leberwerte und Glukoswerte.
Ach ja, weil sie Diabetikerin ist. Ja, genau.
Und auch im Urin
werde ich eine Urinkultur veranlassen.
Was lassen Sie im Urin untersuchen?
Im Urin-Untersuchung zunächst Mikroskopie,
danach Urinkultur. Ah, okay.
Gut. Wie geht es dann weiter?
Wie werden die Laborsachen auf den Weg geschickt?
Danach werde ich
Operativmaßnahmen durchführen. Ja, und was liegt da als erstes?
Besonders
Abdomen-Sonographie oder
ich kann sagen besonders
die Sonographie. Ah, ja, okay.
Und gegebenenfalls werde ich
CT-Abdomen ohne Kontrast durchführen.
Ja, okay, gut. Wenn sich jetzt
Ihre Vermutung bestätigt, was wäre denn für Sie
die angemessene Therapie? Was meinen Sie?
Sie hat keine
Fieber, aber sie hat Fiebergefühl.
Vielleicht hat sie eine
Pylonephritis.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose als Pylonephritis bestätigen,
werde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Danach werden wir Zugang legen und ausreichende
Verlustigkeit zuvor. Und als
asymptomatische Therapie
anadriertikum, spasmodikum, antipiritikum und
antibiotikum. Ja, also nicht
nicht-mordlich-Medikamente. Gut, ja. Gut, dann halten Sie mich
auf dem Laufenden, was die Untersuchungsergebnisse sind für die Frau Krämer.
Und wenn Sie die tatsächlich stationär aufnehmen,
gucken wir heute Abend oder sonst im zweiten Morgen
gucken wir uns die Patienten nochmal an und schauen dann,
wie es ihr nach den ersten Maßnahmen geht.
Okay, gut. Ja. Ja, und auch nach dem
Kulturergebnisse vom Laufen, werde ich
kalkulierte Antibiotherapie. Dann haben wir eine Erregerpassende.
Ja, sehr schön. Ja. Gut, Herr Dr. Ates,
das war ja ein Heimspiel für Sie, kann man sagen.
Sie waren in Ihrem Fachgebiet zu Hause.
Ja, da kann man, ich weiß es ja nicht vorher, was passiert.
Ja, es war für Sie natürlich insofern
ein leichtes, aber Sie haben sich auch so wirklich
bravourös geschlagen, muss ich sagen. Was mir sehr gut
gefallen hat, dass Sie schon gleich von Anfang an
sehr, also einmal haben Sie die Patienten nett angesprochen,
eine Winzigkeit.
Ich habe einige persönliche Fragen, da zucke ich immer so ein bisschen
zusammen. Persönliche Fragen sind
in unserem Sprachgebrauch
so private Fragen. Also eine persönliche Frage,
was weiß ich, so
was wären das, sexuelle Vorlieben oder sowas, das wäre was sehr
Persönliches. Und das andere, ich habe Fragen zur
Person. Das ist was anderes. Persönliche Fragen sind eher so private Fragen.
Ich habe erstmal ein paar Fragen zur Person.
Das ist ein winziger sprachlicher Unterschied.
Oder persönliche Daten, ja, das passt auch.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten,
das kann man natürlich auch machen. Aber wie gesagt, persönliche Fragen,
das ist so ein bisschen privat. Aber ansonsten war das wunderbar,
weil Sie die Patientin sehr schön angesprochen haben immer.
Und was mir super gut gefallen hat, Sie haben wirklich
eine vorbildliche Variation an
Frageanfängen gehabt. Ist Ihnen aufgefallen? Haben Sie bemerkt?
Also dieses ewige Haben Sie haben Sie bemerkt?
Dieses ewige Haben Sie haben Sie haben Sie haben Sie absolut vermieden.
Und das war super. Das hat mir richtig richtig gut gefallen.
Von Anfang an hatte ich ja so ein bisschen die Probleme,
dass Sie sehr leise sprechen. Aber das kommt natürlich auch,
das kommt sehr ruhig und sehr
fokussiert drüber. Und
ich hatte zwar so von der Akustik manchmal Probleme,
das zu verstehen oder musste sehr genau hinhören.
Aber diese sehr ruhige Art
kommt halt so beim Patienten gut an.
Ich fühlte mich gut aufgehoben,
dass Sie eben ja nicht laut waren
und so unaggressiv gefragt haben. Ja, das war sehr angenehm.
Und jetzt muss ich gerade überlegen,
ob ich mir noch irgendwas aufgeschrieben habe.
Nee, da war nix. So und dann kam
ja, was ich ein bisschen ungewöhnlich fand,
das war Ihre Reihenfolge, dass Sie
erst die Familienanamnese gemacht haben
und dann nach den Vorerkrankungen und den Medikamenten gefragt haben.
Das ist ja, das ist so ein bisschen ungewöhnlich,
normalerweise fragt man ja nach den Vorerkrankungen unmittelbar
nach der vegetativen Anamnese.
Das ist so zumindest das Muster, was ich kenne, dass man dann sagt,
ja, was weiß ich, das und das sind jetzt Ihre akuten
Beschwerden. Und gibt es denn bei Ihnen Vorerkrankungen?
Nehmen Sie Medikamente? Und erst danach
ist so im üblichen Ablauf die Frage
nach familiärer Anamnese und dann auch
nach sozialer Anamnese. Aber das kann natürlich
sein, dass das in Stuttgart unüblich ist und dass Sie eine andere
Reihenfolge haben. Es ist mir nur aufgefallen,
sowohl beim Fragen als auch nachher beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
da haben Sie es ja entsprechend analog auch gemacht.
Gut, dann Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch war auch genauso schön ruhig, genauso
konsequent und natürlich,
also dieser Patient oder diese Patientin konnte Ihnen ja nichts
vormachen, weil das wirklich gerade Ihr Fachgebiet ist.
Sie wussten genau, was mit der los ist und Sie haben dann ja auch
der guten Ordnung halbe, haben Sie sich ja auch noch gefragt, ob Sie Herz
oder Artebeschwerden haben. Aber genau genommen wussten Sie ja eigentlich
von vornherein, wo die Reise hingeht. Das war ja ein offenes
Beheimnis für Sie. Gut.
Dann ist nur auch wieder so eine winzige Sprachlichkeit,
sprach, das rede ich schon selber um, Entschuldigung, eine sprachliche
Ungenauigkeit. Die Frage nach schwindelig,
ne, die Frage nach schwindeln.
Also ich habe Sie auch ein paar Mal korrigiert bei so
Kleinigkeiten. Da merkt man dann,
dass Sie beim Freiformulieren nicht ganz so sicher sind,
wie beim Fragestellen. Aber ich denke mal, das sind
ja kleine sprachliche Geschichten, die auch
ja so ein bisschen dazugehören. Das ist ja auch, wenn jemand nicht ganz
perfekt spricht, das hat ja auch einen gewissen Charme, muss man sagen.
Und ja, Sie machen
auch manchmal diese Satzstellung,
ja, wie das praktisch fast alle nicht Muttersprachler machen.
Dann wir schauen nach ihrem
sowieso oder so. Ja, also dass das Verb eben dann nicht an zweiter
Stelle steht. Ja, aber also das ist
einfach eine Kleinigkeit, aber ich hab das jetzt
überhaupt nicht aufregend gefunden. Und natürlich waren
Sie goldrichtig mit Ihrer Pyrrhonephritis und
auch mit den ganzen Untersuchungen,
was mir ja, das ist so ein Klassiker.
Sie haben
Druckschmerz gesagt, Klopfschmerz, Klopfschmerz im Rücken.
Das ist so der Klassiker, wo man nachfragt.
Und das sollte man vielleicht noch mit erwähnen. Aber eben perfekt,
ja, Blutuntersuchung, Urinstatus und Urinkultur.
Ja, was wollen Sie mehr? Ja, und Therapie
natürlich auch genau so, ja, wie Sie es gesagt haben.
Wunderbar. Also gehen Sie mit gutem Gefühl
entspannt ins Wochenende und dann auch in Ihre Prüfung.
Also selbst wenn Sie keinen urologischen Fall kriegen,
wird Ihnen, glaube ich, nicht viel passieren.
Ja, gut, ja, ein vorbildliches Gespräch heute Abend.
Ich denke, wir haben alle auch viel mitbekommen
und viel daraus lernen können. Herzlichen Dank
allen, die wieder mitgemacht haben, zugehört haben.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen jetzt einen netten Abend
und ein schönes Wochenende, wenn es dann soweit ist.
Wir sehen uns sehr gerne am Dienstag wieder.